des locaux flambant neufs que se
partagent pour l'instant 8 praticiens
cinq médecins généralistes deux
sages-femmes et un ostéopathe viennent
de s'installer dans cette maison
médicale
un projet qui remonte en 2016 avec
seulement quatre médecins généralistes
aubergenville est un désert médical
les praticiens installés sur la commune
tire la sonnette d'alarmé
à l'heure actuelle en moyenne tous les
jeux j'ai entre 40 et 80 personnes par
jour et mois qui commence très tôt le
matin souvent g20 personnes devant la
porte qui attendent pour être soigné on
notait surcharge de travail ne peut pas
se permettre de prendre les patients des
alentours
c'était impossible alors que là bas
toutes les personnes qui viendront
seront vus au minimum par un médecin
pour permettre à ce projet de voir le
jour la mairie d'aubergenville a mis à
disposition des locaux et propose un
loyer modéré un argument pour attirer
notamment les jeunes praticiens ils ont
des difficultés à s'installer parce
qu'ils ont peur de l'avenir
on ne peut pas dire que ça soit une voie
royale et des cabinets la création de
cabinets médicaux comme ceux ci leur
permettre de se rassurer sur leurs
exercices futurs
et je pense que ça un rôle important
dans l'installation des jeunes confrères
un projet également porté par le
département des yvelines dans sa volonté
de lutter contre les déserts médicaux
d'ici à 2022 vingt établissements de ce
type couvriront le territoire des
yvelines pour les trois années qui
viennent 30,2 millions d'euros vont être
investis à la fois pour accompagner les
communes qui veulent construire des
maisons médicales et nous construirons
nous mêmes dans les communes qui n'ont
pas les moyens des maisons médicales
mais nous les gérons donc c'est un plan
d'une ampleur considérable pour trois
ans et si c'est nécessaire naturellement
c'est un plan que nous pourrons suivre
très prochainement c'est un maul que
sera posée la première pierre de la
première maison médicale départementale